we need heroes
like you
[Music]
I'm ready
captain marvel get tickets now hey
what's up everyone its Warren and we
have a brand new Captain Marvel Avengers
hero TV spot as well as some reviews and
reactions from people who actually got
to see a screening of Captain Marvel
last night it's getting really close
until it comes out in theaters we have
less than half a month left and the
reviews and the reactions from the
screening last night are just off the
charts good so it's getting really
exciting I'll talk about this new TV
spot and the reactions and the reviews
in this video also I'm giving away five
imax tickets if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so Captain Marvel is the last
Marvel MCU film that we'll see before
Avengers end game comes out it comes out
the month before in game hits theaters
and we know from the post-credits scene
of Avengers infinity war that Captain
Marvel will be in Avengers in game so
the first part of this trailer is sort
of tying in Captain Marvel to the rest
of the Avengers showing the main
Avengers Tony Stark Steve Rogers and
Thor because she's going to be with them
in the next Avengers film not to mention
Avengers in game is going to wrap up the
story arc from the first ten years of
the MCU and with the ending of the first
ten years we'll start a new phase which
Captain Marvel is going to lead so the
first part of this trailer is tying in
Captain Marvel Carol Danvers with the
rest of the heroes and the MCU and then
we have one new scene in this TV spot
that's really important in this scene we
can actually see Carol Danvers crash her
plane and we can see the alien ship that
shot her down Chaser as you can see her
plane is on fire this is most likely a
Skrull ship that is chasing her although
it could be a Kree ship based on what
we've seen in the other Captain Marvel
trailers we know that a scroll and a
Kree are both on the plane crash site
and we know that this is most likely
where she gets her powers from in the
movie we get an even better look at the
explosion on the crash site where we see
this energy go inside of her body most
likely giving her her powers we get a
close-up look at her hand in the
explosion and you can see the energy
flow inside of her and fuse with her so
that's it for the important new scenes
in this new TV spot but like I said
there was a screening for Captain Marvel
last night and the reviews are insanely
good I'll put a few of them on the
screen so you can see but almost every
review that I've read
that the movie is just incredible what's
really interesting is that many people
described this movie as awesomely weird
it's also been described as unexpected
trippy ambitious and is said to have a
sci-fi feel to it the movie is also said
to have a bunch of Easter eggs relating
to the history and other films of the
MCU a lot of reviews also say that bin
Mendelsohn steals the movie with his
character Talos but everybody
unanimously says that the main star of
the movie is goose
effortless enigmatic fearless
talented refined iconic
you know thanks Bree oh I was actually
just talking about this oh yeah well yes
Oh was I
[Music]
I can definitely see why goose would be
the favorite so that's it for the new TV
spot and reviews for Captain Marvel it's
said to be an amazing movie and comes
out in less than a month so let me know
what you're most excited about don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Captain Marvel Avengers in game and
Marvel in general as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you